hi my name is Nina today I'm going to
show you how to make hummus we have
friends coming over it later so I'm
gonna prepare some homers and I'm I've
already cooked the quinoa salad hummus I
I always make from scratch I bought a
bag of chickpeas and then I soaked maybe
a little bit in the bow overnight you
can see just your water in there wash it
I like to wash my being so the water
it's half boil it'sit's actually how I
could put the chippies in there the home
is it's very healthy and then it's yummy
I like I like the taste the taste of the
home is I always eat the hummus with
with cucumber I cut the cucumber up in a
strong steak and I dip it into the
hummus or carrot you can also get
tortilla chips and crackers if you want
and chickpeas it has 35,000 iron only
woman need iron I women need iron they
always low in nine do you really want to
go into details me so we're gonna wait
for chippies to cook I mean to boil and
to cook and then i'll show you how to
blend it up later how I know when it's
ready is I take one chippy out eat it or
you press it down with your fingers oh
did this free to our friend who is
joining us to the party and she just got
back from England England
and what are you doing in archaeology
discovering the yes ancient Greek
civilization ok cool so chippies then
I'm gonna pour the water out ok so I'm
gonna have Rachel to some chippies in
here about let's say about maybe 14 14
nouns one is another escapes okay
one more than I think we're about sports
announces
we're gonna put 2 tbsp up Tina that's
oily
frequently used in Greek cuisine yeah
listen listen um Gomez's great snack yes
very frequently all around the
Mediterranean the eastern Mediterranean
we bought this garlic minced garlic from
costco I don't like chopping the garlic
it's too much work so this is easy to
use so 1 1 teaspoon I love garlic the
next ingredient will be the cumin sauce
about one table 1 teaspoon to listen
usually it's 1 teaspoon but I always I
like I really like the taste I always
come more than one teaspoon in my homies
then we are yep and then just just to
taste for salt maybe half of teaspoon
just to taste and then this is the
paprika powder doubt it will be 1 tsp 2
20 t spoon very carefully
and then i will ask some booty Cotto's
the water from the the juice from the
chippies or you can use water but i'm
gonna use this oops boy I shouting about
see oh I don't have enough chippy jus so
a little bit water the faux half bubbly
8 ounces or nine now sis is fine okay
and then we're gonna blend it up this is
our Vitamix we love our Vitamix we use
this for the smoothie
the thing we were mapped out a little
bit more water because there's still two
to dry
Oh Elise it doesn't look dry mm-hmm
Jimmy dan I'm gonna make it a little bit
prettier net hats sign i'm going to ask
some paprika sauce on the top in the
middle
up here go I'm going to head out some
cucumbers
okay Rachel thank you very much I'm so
excited to try this it looks delicious
you should you should stay home okay
Cheers touch one yeah doctors do one
mm-hmm tell me not try really good
thanks hmm so creamy I supposed to be
the screaming yes creamy it's always
creamy okay thank you for watching this
video if you liked the video please give
a thumbs up and enjoy subscribe by
believe why are you looking at me it's
great oh yeah I did something wrong but
I shouldn't say this in front of the
camera well it's a big messy okay who's
that closing make sure to check out my
newsletter you're gonna love it